a nascar driver
is in a lot of trouble
there's this nascar driver
uh this nascar driver
came out
and he used a word you're not allowed to
say take a listen well he drills my ass
coming out of four for no reason i mean
where was he going what was he gonna do
spin me out he was trying to do a
harvick is what he was trying to do
for what for second place to do what he
wasn't gonna transfer through with that
just freaking [ __ ] man so stupid i
don't understand these guys i should
beat the [ __ ] out of them right now is
what i should do but that doesn't do me
any good either
and that i've already had to pay enough
fines in my lifetime i'm sure i'll get
another
one spoken like a true nascar driver
really blunt really direct he didn't get
in trouble for saying i'm going to go
beat the [ __ ] out of somebody no that's
fine
talking about he's going to go beat
somebody up that's totally fine but he
said a word you're not allowed to say he
said the word [ __ ]
that's
the r word
some people are now calling it
because he was saying this guy he did
something that was a little stupid a
little slow he shouldn't have done that
that was [ __ ] and you're not allowed
to say [ __ ] anymore
why not why not why can't what does
[ __ ] mean [ __ ] means
slow
it's literally what the word means
but we're not allowed to say that
because some people
are a little slower right this is if
this is
fallen world we've all got defects we've
all got problems none of us is born
perfect
and so some some people
deal with that and that's a challenge in
their lives
what what we're seeing play out right
now is something called the euphemism
treadmill that's what the harvard
psychologist stephen pinker dubbed it
it's this idea that
certain
phrases and words will change over time
and political correctness has really
taken this to a sort of insane extreme
because the condition that they describe
is undesirable or difficult or painful
and so you just have to constantly paper
over with a new euphemism
you see this especially with a mental
deficiency
so over the years people with mental
handicaps have been called simple
simpletons idiots that was a that was a
clinical term [ __ ]
um
[ __ ]
handicapped handicapable what it's going
to keep it's going to keep changing
it's not going to help anybody
it's not going to fix anything to keep
changing all of those words but it's
going to keep
creating all of these euphemisms so that
we can ignore things
for the left
what you say
is much more important than what you do
the left around the west and in this
country as well
openly advocate killing [ __ ] people
in the womb
iceland bragged a couple of years ago
they said we've we've eliminated down
syndrome we've eradicated down syndrome
they didn't find a cure for down
syndrome they just kill all the down
syndrome babies in the womb
they will kill them in in this country
there are doctors who will
i guess most if not all of the doctors
will will say when you're when you're
pregnant they'll say okay we're going to
do a scan to see if your kid has and
they'll use whatever euphemism but
they'll what they're really saying is
we're going to scan to see if your kid's
[ __ ] and then if your kid's [ __ ]
you can kill him if you want
this is ghastly this is ghastly stuff so
the conservative response to this is one
i don't want you
scanning to see if my kid's [ __ ] i'm
going to love my kid no matter how my
kid turns out he's got six fingers and
12 toes and has some mental handicap and
looks i don't care i love my kid
and the left you know what the left is
going to say to that how dare you use
the word [ __ ] you say you're going
to kill him what are you talking i'm
using a word to describe a reality and i
want to love all of these people
but you're saying no no don't say the
word don't describe the reality
but kill people that you don't like kill
people who you find undesirable
for though it's a very important lesson
about political correctness
what you see and really just for the
left's program broadly what you say
is much more important than what you do
often what you say
is a way to excuse really evil heinous
actions this is very offensive this is
very wrong i'm glad you like that clip i
liked it too if you want more of them
subscribe ring the bell more importantly
than that though because sometimes
our friends on some of these platforms
don't send notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]
you